the monster verse has kicked off to a
great start with three movies including
the most recently released Godzilla -
king of the monsters with the box-office
success of his tree movies it has opened
up the possibilities of expanding the
franchise to a scale unplanned for the
next movie in the making is Kong vs.
Godzilla which will be released in 2020
and hopefully will not be subject to any
delay in production or postponement of
the debut day aside from this chitchat
most of us has teased us with the
possibilities of our world being sort of
hollow in reality and this is not a fan
theory it is the remarks by dr. Randall
in Skull Island that assured us of such
a thing the Hollow Earth theory in
monster verse isn't the same as The
Journey to the Center of the Earth scan
of world in a monster verse the earth
has numerous large portals to
underground hollow cavities that allow
Titans and other creatures to exist
undetected by humanity his entry and
exit points sometimes have kind of a
vortex like a wormhole that allows for
faster travel and also shot a
displacement relative to surface
distance based on these three movies and
a novelization of the king of the
monsters movie we have counted at least
15 different locations for Hollow Earth
portals or entry points all over the
world number one Skull Island in the
2017 movie Kong Skull Island humans on
the monarch went to the mysterious Skull
Island and their seismic geologists
conducted a study on the presence of
Hollow Earth's portals theorized to be
present there unfortunately the kind of
instruments they were using for studies
were bombs and napalm which angered the
king of the island Kong we found out
that yes these portals do exist but the
u-turn actions they awakened the
monstrous skull crawlers that dwelled
deep under the earth and come out from
these entry points this led to a battle
between dem Kong and a skull crawler
species on a species towards the latter
part of the movie a giant skull crawler
emerge from a portal and almost cost in
everyone's life including Kong number
two South American coast and the king of
the monsters movie godzilla approached
castle Bravo station located in the
Bermuda Triangle
soon afterwards monarch started
following Godzilla as she predicted that
his movements were taking him to
Antarctica to an outpost that was the
location of monster zero
Godzilla suddenly disappeared from their
detection instruments which indicates
that he entered a portal leading to the
Hollow Earth which has a lot of other
openings that he could have emerged
elsewhere mana
continued this flight to earth monster
zeros location sensing that the place
was in jeopardy number three
Antarctica when mark went to Antarctica
they confronted the eco-terrorists and
dr. Russell turned cold and awakened
monster zero from hibernation under the
ice sheet everything seemed dim and
hopeless against such a Thailand until
an eerily familiar sound was heard and
blue lights were seen from under the ice
sheet godzilla emerged from under the
ice which says a lot more than just a
dramatic entrance it also shows that the
entry point from where Godzilla
disappeared near the South American
coast was connected to the portal that
was under the ice sheet in Antarctica
this was the first showdown between the
two Alpha Titans which was just epic
number four cause of Isla de Moura
following the battle that ensued in
Antarctica and Ghidorah flying away
going to US direction of orcas signal
that was played in Isla de Moura in the
Gulf of Mexico there were a series of
battles between Ronan and Ghidorah and
later on between Godzilla and Ghidorah
underwater Godzilla had the upper hand
in battle as he was in his element
just as Ghidorah has the upper hand when
he took the big G to the upper
atmosphere and dropped him like a bomb
so just as things were looking good for
the big G and humanity as Godzilla was
literally killing it underwater by an
oxygen destroyer weapon sent by the
military on a missile which nearly
killed Godzilla the big G disappeared
severely wounded and retreated via
another entry point which was connected
to his underwater Kingdom a prehistoric
extinct human civilization which might
as well be Atlantis number 5 Bermuda
while searching for Godzilla and all
hope seemingly lost for humans as king
ghidorah was now the Alpha and all the
Titans have been awakened and were
hunting like a pack all over the world
Matra showed up and net the humans to
another portal near Castle Bravo in
Bermuda this portal led them directly to
Godzilla and with Serizawa sacrifice
they resurrected
with a nuclear weapon and re-emerge
again at the surface in moralist nearby
the Bermuda Triangle this might as well
be counted as two portals number six
isla de mar of volcano this is a
probable location for another Hollow
Earth entry point the place where Rodin
was hibernating volcanoes in general are
pathways to the inner regions of the
world whether the inner cross or the
magma filled mantle the high probability
of this place to be a portal to the
Hollow Earth is because Rodin was
situated in it and might have been
guarding the entrance as well as
hibernating in it Rodin is a fire
destroy a time as we all know hence not
being affected by the extreme heat from
the lava number seven Marianas Trench it
has been noted that in the movies and a
novelization of the movies that Godzilla
was traveling under water in the Pacific
Ocean and when he reached the Marianas
Trench the sonar couldn't detect his
presence anywhere
It was as if he disappeared without a
trace this could have only meant that
there was another portal that connected
the deepest point in the earth to the
hollow cavities beneath the earth's
crust and open up in another different
location number eight eastern Indian
Ocean when Godzilla when Godzilla
disappeared under the Marianas Trench
monarch who was monitoring his movements
were dumbstruck as to where they could
have lost a hundred thousand ton 550
feet long Titan from their sensors
Godzilla it seems re-emerged in the
Indian Ocean just of the coast of
Indonesia which tells us that the pole
in the Marianas Trench was connected to
the portal in the Indian Ocean a sort of
an Eastern underwater superhighway a
distance of several thousand kilometers
was Scott Shaw
as we all know by a vortex allowed for
faster movement and shorter displacement
number nine Loch Ness in a novelization
of the king of the monsters movie a
Titan was discovered in the Loch Ness
Scotland in the United Kingdom and an
outpost was built around it this Titan
was dubbed Aztec Terrace Leviathan this
creature was the source of the legends
behind a mountainous monster which is as
we can imply looked like a bless you sir
or an underwater sauropod dinosaur when
Ghidorah song of the Alpha called it
awakened all the Titans and Titanes
Leviathan as well
he now joined all the other Titans
except for
Godzilla and Matra on a worldwide hunt
will sneer back after destroying the
mana outpost it disappeared suddenly
which means it went down under number 10
northern Indian Ocean the Leviathan
re-emerged in the Indian Ocean and
started to terrorize shipping vessels
with the majority of the shipping route
being in the course of Africa the red
sea and going through the northern part
of the Indian Ocean to eastern Asia it
can well be implied that Titanus
Leviathan was hunting in a northern
Indian Ocean shipping lane number 11
Eastern Atlantic Ocean this is a
possible entry point that is terrorized
as where Methuselah traveled from to get
to Boston in the United States to help
this alpha king ghidorah Titanus
Methuselah is the oldest and biggest
Titan aside from Ghidorah in size this
Titan was monitored in an OP East Island
was monitored in an outpost just outside
Munich Germany when Ghidorah is on the
DL for call Methuselah was awakened and
immediately after he woke up he was
bombarded by bumps from fighter jet
fired at by tanks and also artillery but
only served as a nuisance to his
extremely durable and dense high so an
emmy rossum son of the arc in boston all
times reacted and were converging in on
the location methuselah being an ocean
away and the forest Titan that actually
reached Boston after the battle couldn't
have made it all the way by swimming it
is terrorized that there is an
underwater portal just off the coast of
France in the Atlantic Ocean which
allowed Titans Methuselah to travel to
the western hemisphere number 12
North American coast so the port of
theorized to have led Titanus Methuselah
to travel from Europe to North America
was underwater in the Atlantic Ocean
it would have meant that another portal
a sort of an exit point was need for him
to reimburse from the Hollow Earth to be
seen in North America
Boston being in the eastern coast of the
United States man that the exit point
would have been off the coast of the US
if it was on land and it would have been
detected so Titanus Methuselah reached
Boston but was too late and witnessed
every other Titan present ere barring
down to the new Alpha the king of the
monsters of course he followed suit in
case you missed it
Methuselah was seen at the last scene
where the scene was zoomed out and
Godzilla's
is legendary roar number 13 southern
Indian Ocean in the novelization of the
king of the monsters movie another Titan
was discovered in the Indian Ocean as it
was curling its silver on a nuclear
submarine meaning that it was feeling of
the radiation present in the nuclear
fuel of the submarine all the warheads
of the nuclear missiles at half in its
inventory the Kraken was chased away by
the military and invaded them by
becoming invisible
therefore it could be said that the
Kraken was awakened or came out of
hiding from another portal leading to
the hollows in the earth located in the
Indian Ocean
number 14 Sedona Arizona the oil field
that was the hibernating phase for
Scylla is another probable location for
a portal the justification for this
chair is that Scylla was classified as
an amphibious Titan which had arachnid
like legs much like those of a crab or
spiders and also split like heaven now
the question stands as to why would an
amphibious or semi aquatic Titan emerge
from underneath a desert the best answer
we can give us that this Titan must have
traveled before to a portal located
under water and re-emerge in Arizona but
seeing that it was a desert in mine f as
well hibernated number 15 Brazil the
final poll in this list is yet unsure
since the items behemoth was awakened in
the tin guap reserve in Brazil which is
located south of Rio de Janerio the
mammoth sloth island start to rampage
across Rio but when the Orca device was
sounded it reached Boston in time to see
Godzilla become the new king but how
would a slow-moving mammoths / sloth
Titan traveled so far in such a short
amount of time
well the amazon forest along with his
deep lakes or river itself might host
another such portal as - a latte thomas
behemoth to be a part of the coronation
ceremony well this brings us to the end
of the list so be sure to LIKE share and
all that fun stuff yeah notification
bell regular actual notifications